hi and welcome back to DevOps 2013 I'm
here with Dan to talk about a service
that Google is offering to game
developers so welcome Dan thank you well
tell us what this is really about and
who we're targeting with this sure well
you know the service is Google Play game
services and developers have been asking
us for a long time you know how to help
them you know find users and how to help
them engage users and more importantly
how to give them some features they've
been desperately wanting and we put
together a service that gives users what
they've been wanting for a long time
which is cloud save
we have achievements which and
leaderboards which drive engagement okay
and what's really exciting about this is
we haven't just done this for Android
but we've actually made this a
cross-platform solution hence the name
it's not the Android service it's the
Google exactly it's a Google service and
it's really important because we know we
recognize that people want to play games
with not just their friends who own
Android devices but they want to be able
to play games with their iOS friends
friends with other devices and of course
people who are using the web and Chrome
ok great so a lot of people can can use
this so people have been using other
cities as solutions before here we're
offering this as a service obviously
it's a Google service you would expect
you know there's the scale there's to be
always up and and and and so how about
sign-in is there any identity
integration so we do use Google+
identity and that's really important
because we wanted privacy to be
paramount at the you know from from the
very start of this service and Google+
gives us the ability to give the users
the kind of privacy controls they expect
from Google and and that's really
importantly there was a lot of
resistance to a lot of different sign
ins that we were seeing and so we said
our what do we need to do in order to
make sure we get as many people as
comfortable with signing in and sharing
their game activity with the people they
want to share it with as possible and so
I mean it really was a no brainer for us
to look at at Google+ identity so you
are one other person that looks after
developers that build games
that's been going so far I mean there's
I mean there's a huge amount of
excitement for it you know they I mean
again users have been really wanting us
for a long time and people have actually
been asking me whether it's been
developers whether it's been you know
gamers they've been coming up to me and
say please please do something in this
space you know show and and I think
what's exciting is we didn't just do
something but we were really doing
something with a very broad reach you
know we didn't we didn't we could have
done something very very simple I think
and instead we chose to really go in
with a tremendous service and what's
exciting to me is you know it's a Google
service and you know game developers
were really really worried in the past
they would go and they would choose a
service that did some of these things
the company would cancel it or as it
would scale it would start costing them
a lot of money and you know what's great
is we're providing the service to game
developers for free across all these
different platforms worth mentioning and
if and if they're successful they don't
end up losing out because the service is
going to scale with them it's not going
to start costing them money they can be
comfortable that the service is going to
be around and that's that's exciting for
me so one of the features is multiplayer
games yes and and how how does that
really work and is that real-time as a
what kind of gaming really can I build
with that I can't live I didn't even
mention that at the beginning but yeah
so one of the most important features we
do is real-time multiplayer gaming and
that allows a developer to create a mesh
network with currently up to up to three
of their friends so a four player mesh
network okay and then it's real time
gaming and it's great because it chooses
the fastest route it can between the
four players so if you're on a local
network it will actually choose a route
that you know that will connect directly
between the players for really really
high speed low latency gaming and it
will also ping our servers and do
natural versal for you if you need to do
a play a game over the Internet so it's
really really powerful and again what's
great is it you know in order to do this
without like google scale you know you
would have to have machines and data
centers all around the world in order to
try to get low latency connections and
Google's is providing us because we want
to make the gaming experience great
awesome so you know I have a built a
game I know how to build games say on
Android let's take that example what
does it take for me to actually
integrate with that service and how hard
is it your attitude existing game to it
I mean that that's one of the things
that's great is it it's actually on
Android all depends on which platform
you're on of course
on Android we've made it part of Google
Play services so it's a part of things
that people have already got on their
device we're constantly pushing updates
to that constantly making the platform
better and all they have to do is
integrate a very very simple library
that we put together we have tons of
sample code for them including a bunch
of great little sample games that
illustrate all the different features
and we actually do code lab here at
devoxx where we had people integrate
Google Play services with a game it took
about 20 minutes for most of them to get
the basic stuff all integrated and it's
and it's exciting it's exciting to see
how quickly people can move on it on iOS
we also provide a client library and
then for the web it's a series of REST
API and I know those can be used
anywhere of course which is exciting
though it's not just tough focusing on
these two mobile platforms but we wanted
to make sure the experience for Android
and iOS developers was great and that
also allows us to provide us with a lot
of features to those users so for
Android and iOS users for example we
support offline achievements offline
leaderboards all of those kinds of
offline features that people expect I
was gonna get to the offline I commute I
take the metro and you know connectivity
is not always there so it is really
important if someone gets an achievement
offline you know they they want they
want to see it pop up in the service
they want to see that it's going to get
back to Google eventually and and so we
do is you get the achievement offline on
Android we'll go and sink it in the
background the next time we get
connectivity on iOS we don't do that yet
but the next time you play the game and
you have connectivity it'll make sure to
sync things up okay great
so what is the experience in terms of
the Google Play Developer console do you
get to see how people use your game and
the API so you get you get a couple of
things one is a you do get some basic
analytics on how people are using your
game and I mean obviously I always
recommend people put their own analytics
in as well but as we roll this out
further we're gonna have deeper and
deeper engagement numbers which is
exciting what's also cool is actually we
actually get to see the engagement
numbers as well and this is and I think
this is exciting because you know we
don't track people's usage on Android so
we don't know what games they're playing
but now they're signing in they're
saying yes Google you know we want you
to know about what we're doing and that
gives us a much better way
directing people to games that we know
users love so it's not just a question
of have they downloaded the game but
who's actually playing who's actually
engaging with that content it allows us
to be much smarter in terms of Google
Play and of course we also have the
Google Play games application and that's
great because you can actually go to
this application we have according to
Google Play between 10 and 50 million
downloads of this already ok and and you
can go and see what your friends are
playing and you can also see how your
friends are progressing and so you can
go to leaderboards and you know that's
that's huge for competition like there
are several games that I have played
because I've seen that one of my friends
were playing it and then I realized that
I have to beat their scores on the
leaderboards can I'm naturally somewhat
game competitive I guess so sorry you
know I I see it working just within our
team and and and I and I know it's
working out in the in the in the world
as well so we're sure the developers go
to learn about this so they should go to
developers.google.com slash games
that'll take them to a page talking all
about things that we offer for game
developers and then if you go to gash
slash game slash services that actually
has all the things we're doing with
Google Play game services but do you go
to the main game site there's a lot of
stuff we're doing for game developers
out there I think that it's really
exciting to see Google getting behind
games the way we have and you know the
last year great well then thanks this is
all the time we have for stray try it
out and for my feedback you guys are
online available absolutely you can go
of course the Android developer channel
for the Android app for the Android API
s and of course go to
developers.google.com to learn all more
about what we're doing and to see our
announcements involving slow is a great
place to ask questions as always you
know we have a team that goes and you
know monitors that as well as as well as
making sure that we actually integrate
your feedback you can also actually give
us feedback on our github site that's
actually where we post all the sample
code and you can also post changes or
any any ideas or bug fixes that need to
go there that's a great place to talk
with the team as well cool game on thank
you the game on